so while drew is showing down on her
beautiful pork carnitas
what we're gonna do over here
is actually do uh coconut tres leches
bread pudding which i thought would be a
really nice compliment to your pork
carnitas so the first thing we're gonna
do actually is um you're gonna take some
chala bread and everyone says you know
wait for it to go stale i'm like
um i don't have time to wait for it to
go still i just like to toast it lightly
and that actually will really improve
the texture of your bread pudding it's
going to be um it's going to make it
absorb much better and you want to toast
it just a little slightly
you can absolutely do it in the oven and
the toaster uh in the toaster oven
however you like to toast your bread and
with that i mix some coconut flakes so
drew i sprayed down the base of this uh
wonderful slow cooker of ours with some
nonstick cooking spray i'm going to toss
the bread coconut oil you could use the
coconut oil which would be really nice
actually because we're using there's
already a little there's coconut in
there and one of our tres leches is a
coconut milk so it's coconut oil
i love coconut milk condensed milk
and regular milk and then i'm making a
mess and then we have like egg yolks
like seven egg yolks basically and two
eggs so you're gonna whisk that until
all the eggs are basically broken up and
homogeneous and then we have a little
bit of cinnamon
actually a lot of cinnamon which is
really nice and some vanilla
and then half a teaspoon of salt are you
impressed i i am loving this also i just
think vanilla cinnamon is one of my
favorite but paired with the coconut
it's just like it's this incredible
flavor it's really really lovely there's
also a little bit of like a unique
french toast element happening
absolutely is a french toast element so
we're going to pour that hopefully fully
beaten custard in
i know i mean it smells amazing guys i'm
totally happy ty
and then what you're gonna do actually
is just with your spatula just press
down a little so the bread starts to
soak
and you're gonna let it sit for about 10
to 15 minutes before you turn it on
really and all that does is basically
let um let the custard be absorbed
into the bread so that when you cook it
it starts to give you all these
different textures you can have a little
crunchy a little soft a little moist
and then you just kick it on
to low
and that takes two and a half to three
hours
and it's done
i'm going to cut myself a slice let me
put that over there
and the last thing we're going to do
drew
is that we actually made a dulce de
leche go give it a lick it's really good
thank you we made the dulce de leche you
know where my mind is i'm like
we made it in the slow cooker as well
yep
so that's the leave overnight
the canyon don't do anything to it and
i'm gonna garnish wait a minute how do
you make this cause this is incredible
you put the whole can of condensed milk
into the slow cooker fill it with water
that goes two inches above the can
and set it to low for eight hours it is
amazing guys this tastes like chocolate
caramel
shall we give the taste
oh my gosh okay i'm going in oh my gosh
it does have texture
it has a lot of texture it's soft and
moist but it's got crunch and
toastedness oh my god and it's it's
great for a crowd it keeps for a few
days you can even freeze it and reheat
it's really really wonderful
you guys this is i'm just going
i just went and literally went like this
yes i mean
this is one of the maybe that's how you
should serve it like with a can out and
people just i do like this presentation
you guys have got to make this this is
incredible it is like caramel and
chocolate had a love child and it's
right here
this is so good thank you for always
expanding our horizons
and uh
just like this meal pilar
i think they make a great combo
just like us
[Music]